unlike wrestling I haven't spent my time
you know since last year playing chess
so it's the it's my first called serious
chess experience after Orson Lewis in
August 2017
while Veselin had quite a few
tournaments and he's still an active
player it's water under the bridge you
know it's I don't complain about spilled
milk but my last game I played in
professional chess I played against him
and I lost so it's always nice just to
have a chance to take revenge it will it
would have been important if I knew it
was the last game but thinking back my
the first time I won against him from
for some reason it's more it's more
memorable than that last game I mean if
you ask me now when which was the date
it happened I don't remember and Gary he
remembers all these special dates for
him it's an opportunity so I guess maybe
I can just settle his old score their
overall score is in my favor but that's
the glass get me Linares that's that I
missed an easy draw and it was tough for
me to play because I knew it was my last
game and in professional chess but now
sudden good news later I have a chance
to to continue this struggle okay I take
the challenge you know equal terms
because as I said Fischer random
eliminates one of the main advantages of
of the top players over a retired player
that's the nobody theory and we have to
stop from scratch
you